et continuerons à exercer notre palais
avec la semaine du goût elle tombe à
point de plus en plus de jeunes français
malheureusement ne connaissent plus
grand chose à la saveur des légumes par
exemple ou des produits traditionnels le
ministre de l'agriculture donnant le
coup d'envoi de cette manifestation ce
matin a même estimé que protéger le goût
et les saveurs c'est défendre un modèle
de civilisation mary pierce amitié jean
louis malle à
dos de saumon fumé en croûte de pommes
de terre crème de poireaux sur grains de
caviar caviar français agrémenté de
trois gouttes d'huile d'argan le jeune
chef yannick alléno 35 ans a repris les
fourneaux de l'hôtel meurice à paris et
déjà il fait preuve d'audace il puise
son imagination bouillonnante dans la
cuisine d'autrefois qu'ils réinventent
on a
après un gros de chasse frottis avec 1
incana t en transparence de l'eau chaude
en chantier l'essence de truffes on a
des choses et non latins novatrice car
ici la high tech est au service de
l'imagination pour retrouver le goût de
la cuisine d'autrefois la cuisson doit
être parfaitement réussi
on a un cas largement des rosés ont
porté à 51 il lui a aussi permis qu'on
va me répondre si 57e certains vivent
avec l'offre d'acs qui lui est en
recherche perpétuelle pour marier les
saveurs et redonner vous aux légumes a
par exemple les blettes du jardin et le
céleri yannick alléno a fait se gratta
intitulé côtes de blettes à la moelle et
au parmesan un plat qu'il vient
d'inventer il demande son avis à une
diététicienne
moi j'ai besoin de savoir
l'apport nutritionnel de chaque produit
2,2 de savoir un peu ce ballet aux
profondeurs je juge aussi cuisiner si
vous voulez jugement une information de
praticité sur sur simplement les
aliments quoi son obsession ne pas
altérer le goût des légumes et faire une
cuisine légère pour cela il faut sans
cesse se poser les bonnes questions
comment on peut
améliorez allégée de son assiette au
quotidien faire en sorte qu'on mange oui
mais on sent que ça me pénalise au
niveau calorique et niveau 2 et remettre
en cause de santé c'est cela le bon goût
retrouvez les pleins d'autres fois qu'on
avait un peu oublié